[Musique]
une semaine fantastique une grande
expérience pour tous les spectateurs
et puis voilà en plus à la fin c'est
l'europe qui gagne donc c'est génial peu
particulier on sent tous émus bah oui
oui ça c'est c'est c'est la fin d'une
histoire mais méhaignerie
[Musique]
quelques regrets on était à domicile on
espérait
peut-être avoir des résultats des
meilleurs résultats on a tenté
12h02 les sportifs sont sortis assez
rapidement
dans les manches de qualification donc
quelques regrets
[Musique]
malgré tout il avait fait planer c est
parce qu on a abordé ce match là pour
parler remporter
[Musique]
on n'a pas remporté ce match mais je
tiens à saluer le courage l'abnégation
et le coeur que mes joueurs ont mis sur
ce match
ils sont plus grands plus costaud plus
lourd plus rapide plus vifs
160 sur le banc de
on n'avait aucune chance à nouveau le
match mais ça m'a fait travailler vous
avez raison que la réponse que je serai
en trajectoire de balle après on n'a pas
question qu'on appelait puissance très
difficile en fait un bon match dans sa
globalité et j'ai trouvé ça super
intéressant en planque lendemain
c'est à retordre
[Musique]
je prends ce n'est pas la plus vive
youzhny a scellé mais tous mes
techniques
technique se déplacer
[Musique]
c'était très plaisant de gagner
aujourd'hui aussi d'obtenir le maillot
jaune ce sera sympa de le porter ce
maillot jaune demain aujourd'hui c'était
une étape très dure avec beaucoup de
vent mais l'équipe a fait du très bon
travail avec est six coureurs dans le
premier groupe
[Musique]
il ya beaucoup de choses qui bougent
beaucoup mais à côté et c'est dans ce
top donc sur l'esprit c'est difficile
mais moi je suis content d'avoir fini
j'ai pas regardé capacité pulmonaire
donc j'ai vu que ma force de volonté
m
la magie du quidditch c'est pouvoir
mélanger plusieurs sports pour en créer
un nouveau
et après on est sûr d'une manipulation
de balle sur du dodge ball à on a les
américains on est sur la même
manipulation ballon de volée
[Musique]
on récupère cette première place qu'ils
ont occupé les trois quarts de l'année
ça fait vraiment plaisir tout le mérite
en revient aux joueurs au staff au
sikkim en un qui m'accompagne à la
direction qui m'a fait confiance cette
année est vraiment fier aussi de
terminer meilleure défense de la ligue
de paris
[Musique]
tazzari med gym à six coeurs en
cassation
tous les altos qu'ils font
ça me donne des idées
[Musique]
de la compétition approche plus agrandi
pour iliad effervescents son club c'est
bien pour nous c'est positif
les enfants ils sont pleins d'énergie
donc on en prend c'est bien
[Musique]
c'est toujours valorisant d'être sur un
terrain de faire partager ce que six
mois ce qui lui a permis de gagner pas
mal de titres
[Musique]
les français étaient là à crier encore
et encore et je me suis dit il faut que
j'aille pop geste et j'ai poussé dans
les bols s'est passé c'est juste
incroyable d'avoir gagné ici